>> NOW ON YESTERDAY AND
CAPITOL HILL CAN CONGRESSWOMAN
WAS PRAISED FOR EXPOSING A FAR
LESS ACTIVIST WHO CLAIMS TO BE
AGAINST VIOLENT RHETORIC BUT
ALSO CALLS FOR SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES TO BE ACCOSTED.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE.
>> AS RHETORIC ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, PROBLEM OF THE
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY MR. WARNER?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> MR. SIEGEL?
>> YES.
MR. MONEY?
YES.
>> ONLY A FEW WEEKS AFTER THE
ATTEMPTED ATTACK ON JUNE 25TH, 1
OF THE WITNESSES TWEETED OUT THE
FOLLOWING A RESPONSE A DECISION
ON ABORTION, OVERTURNING
ROE V. WADE AND I'LL QUOTE
DIRECTLY FROM THE TWEAK, THE SIX
JUSTICES SHOULD NEVER KNOW PEACE
AGAIN.
IT IS OUR CIVIC DUTY TO A COST
TO THEM, EVERY TIME THEY ARE IN
PUBLIC.
THEY ARE PARIAHS.
SINCE WOMEN DO NOT HAVE THEIR
RIGHTS THESE JUSTICES SHOULD
NEVER HAVE A PEACEFUL MOMENT IN
PUBLIC AGAIN.
I HAVE A QUESTION IS THAT YES OR
NO DO YOU BELIEVE YOUR RHETORIC
IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY WHEN
YOU'RE CALLING TO ACCOST A
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, THE
SUPREME COURT?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S THE
CORRECT CHARACTERIZATION.
>> DID YOU NOT TO EAT THAT?
THAT YOU THOUGHT THAT THE PER
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES SHOULD BE
ACCOSTED.
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT
THAT IS NOT AN ACCURATE
CHARACTERIZATION OF MY
STATEMENTS.
>> ALL OF THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
CLAIM TO BE SO CONCERNED ABOUT
VIOLENCE AND THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY, THERE ARE ALSO THE
WANTED TIME THERE SPEWING HATE
THEMSELVES.
ANYWAY HERE WITH MORE REPUBLIC
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA NANCY MACE IS
WITH US.
THERE WAS A A PRETTY BRILLIANT
EXCHANGE, IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE
TO THE CONTRARY.
THEY REALLY DIDN'T DENY THAT
THAT WAS THERE TO RIGHT PLACE.
THEY LEARNED NO SHE COULDN'T
DENY IT DOES WITH HER WORDS IN
BLACK AND WHITE FROM TWITTER
THAT WERE DISPLAYED ON THE BOARD
BEHIND ME, AND HERE'S A
SIGNIFICANTLY HYPOCRITE WHO
ADVOCATES VIOLENCE ONLINE YOU
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T DO IT, BEFORE
ME AND MY COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU SAW YESTERDAY
TO PROVE PREVIEW OF WHAT COULD
HAPPEN NEXT YEAR WHEN THERE IS
NO MANAGEMENT INTERN IN
OVERSIGHT, WHEN YOU COME INTO
THAT ROOM TO TESTIFY, WE'RE
GOING TO SHOW YOU FOR THE
HYPOCRITES THAT YOU ARE BECAUSE
THIS ONE STANDARD FOR THE LEFT,
THEN THIS IS STANDARD FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
AND WHEN YOU RIGHTLY POINTED IT
OUT SEAN.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING IN FRONT
OF OUR COMMUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST HATE SPEECH
IS SPEAKING OUT AGAINST VIOLENT
RHETORIC AS WE ALL SHOULD.
AND THESE ARE THE SAME, THE VERY
SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE USING HATE
SPEECH USING VIOLENT RHETORIC
AGAINST THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
IN THE HYPOCRITES FOR.
>> YOU KNOW, AS WE WATCH DAY
AFTER DAY AFTER DAY OF THE MONTH
OF THE MONTH OF THE MONTH FOR
JANUARY 6 HEARINGS, AND I WAS ON
RADIO REAL-TIME WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
IN A CONDEMNED THE NEW REAL-TIME
AND HAD CONTENDED THAT NIGHT ON
THE SHELF.
THEY HAVE THE SUMMER BEFORE IN
SUMMER 202020, WE HAVE 5,000,074
RIOTS, WE HAD TO THOUSANDS
INJURED COPS, DOZENS OF DEAD
AMERICANS, BENDS OR PROPERTY
DAMAGE HOW COME THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A COMMITTEE LOOKING INTO
THOSE ALLIANCES?
DOESN'T THAT SEEM HYPOCRITICAL.
>> VERY HYPOCRITICAL.
AND FOR THE RECORD THEY DO NOT
QUANTIFY ANTIFA CRIMES, AND
THEY'VE NEVER CHARGE A MEMBER OF
NT FOR THESE ANARCHIST GROUPS TO
CAUSE DISCUSSION AROUND THE
COUNTRY WHICH IS STRAIGHT.
AND I MENTIONED IN MY HEARING
YESTERDAY THAN I'VE BEEN A
VICTIM OF POLITICAL VIOLENCE,
I'VE HAD MY CAR KEYED, MY HOUSE
VACATED, RECENTLY EARLIER THIS
YEAR I HAD HOUSE TRESPASSED.
AGAIN FOR THE SIGHT OF HIM IN
ABOUT A YEAR, AND I DEAL WITH
THREATS DAY IN AND DAY OUT
BECAUSE I SOMETIMES TAKE
POSITION THE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
I'M IN A PURPLE DISTRICT THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS, WE HAVE TO STAND
YOUR GROUND AND STEAK AT THOSE
POSITIONS BUT I CARRY A GUN
EVERYWHERE YOU KNOW WHEN I'M
BACK HOME BECAUSE OF THE
RHETORIC THAT I SEEN OUT THERE
BECAUSE OF THE FEDS HAVE BEEN
ACCOSTED ON THE STREETS IN
PUBLIC PHYSICALLY AND VERBALLY
AND IT IS NOT OKAY IN THE SEE
THESE PEOPLE COME TO CONGRESS
AND SEE THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND SEE HYPOCRISY
AND WHAT THEY BELIEVE DEMOCRACY
SHOULD BE, IT IS NOT HERE WHEN
WE'VE HAD THIS BEAUTIFUL
DOCUMENT OF THIS FOUNDING
FATHERS WE SHOULD BE HOLDING
PEOPLE TO THE FULLEST EXTENT OF
THE LAW REGARDLESS IF THEY HAVE
AN ART OR A DEED BY THEIR NAME
EVEN ABOUT CONDEMNING CERTAIN
PEOPLE, AND WE SHOULDN'T BE BUT
WE SHOULD ALSO BE HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
ONLY SHOWED UP AT THE STEPS OF
SUPREME COURT DUBSTEP WITH A
KNIFE, LOADED PISTOL READY TO
KILL HIM AND HIMSELF.
AND WE NEED TO PUT A STOP TO
THIS NONSENSE IS FINISHED START
JANUARY 3RD.
>> I AGREE COMPLETELY.
AND AS A TALK SHOW HOST, I'VE
HAD THE SAME EXPERIENCES YOU
HA